oh
[Music]
okay
hello
[Music]
uh
basically
is
w
that's all that matters
i wish
[Music]
do
i'm never gonna choose
[Music]
practicing
at the same time
[Music]
okay
good evening
hello
there am i on
almost not yet
i think brett
funtime hello
oh i can already hear this one
oh thank you adam run away mike
this one's really
all right feeling hot try not to let it
squeak
good evening welcome to the table my
name is karen miner and i'm part of the
leadership team here
welcome to all of you that are here
inside and welcome to all of you who are
online we're really glad that you're
joining us tonight
especially this week after easter those
of you that visited during easter
welcome back
um i just have a couple of announcements
to get us started tonight uh first of
all you may have noticed some uh younger
faces in here with us that aren't
usually in here with us we have our kids
joining us yay
good to see you guys
we have a new kids drop-off process so
for our kids that are yeah
yeah you might want to listen up so you
know
so for our kids that are three and up uh
they are all gonna be in here with us
for the first worship song which i think
is great i love one of our values as
being communal and inclusive
and i love that we're gonna have our
kids in here with us for the first song
of worship after the first song is done
someone from our worship team will
dismiss you all and you'll go back there
to that door where britney is standing
and brittany and eve will take you back
to your classes
sound good
yeah okay cool
and then uh secondly we have an online
book club meetup that is starting
actually tomorrow at 7 pm
it's going to be led by one of our
online members stephanie karasik who is
wonderful
and it's just a great way to to connect
with other people at the table if you
enjoy reading books or you want to enjoy
reading books
then you want to be a part of that
if you're here and are interested you
can grab one of these visitor cards it's
back right out the door you came in
and the little table you can fill that
out and just put book club and a way to
get in contact with you
and we will get you connected with
stephanie she'll give you the rest of
the information that you need
if you are online and wanting to attend
the online book club all you need to do
is message the table
on facebook and we'll get get you
connected with stephanie as well
third i want to just give a little
mention because this last month has gone
by so fast next sunday is mark march
next sunday is may 1st which is our
first sunday tradition
uh after the service we're all going to
go to hack creek burger company and sexy
and enjoy dinner together so you were
invited and it's a great time to invite
a friend or family member to join us as
well kids love first sundays too
who doesn't love like eating and playing
right
yeah cool
how about if we
take a second just to quiet ourselves
center ourselves as we enter into
worship so will you pray with me
god thank you for tonight thank you that
we all get to be here together indoors
and online
god i pray that everyone would feel
welcomed and apart
and god we center on you
we remember that we are loved
unconditionally by you
that your grace is for each one of us
help us to believe that god to trust
that to lean into it in greater ways
and i pray that
there's something about the service one
one thing at least that speaks to each
person
who is here and who is watching online
so god we thank you i pray your
blessings over each person hearing my
voice
in your name we pray amen
[Music]
thanks karen will you guys stand with us
and we're gonna get started in our
worship and you are all
welcome and invited to sing along and
participate
um use your hands to clap if you want to
clap use your feet to move
this is a holistic
practice in the christian tradition and
i hope it's not a spectator sport i hope
it's a communal event where we're all
joining in together and lifting up um
statements that we believe to be true
about god the way that he loves us the
way that we interact and love him back
so you guys join in as much as you are
able
[Music]
i'm
you
make all
work things
[Music]
for my future
and for
my good make all things
once together
through your glory
and for
your names
[Music]
there's a healing line
just beyond the clouds
[Music]
is
make all
[Music]
your things
stand apart
[Music]
work together
for my future
[Music]
all things work together
for your glory
and
[Music]
and for my
all things work together
for your glory
and for your name
[Music]
you're an artist and a part
you're
[Music]
and i know nothing has been wasted
no failure or mistakes
[Music]
on the canvas
those words just hit me that last you
know no failure
no mistake
whatever has happened up to this point
it is not
so great that it would separate us from
the love of god it would not separate us
from the good work that he is doing in
our lives
so don't discount yourself
no matter what baggage we carry no
matter what our past whatever marks
against us
whatever our criminal record
he is bigger he is greater and his love
is here and it's available to each one
of us
all right thank you kids for
joining us for our very first time in
our worship service you guys are welcome
now to be dismissed and go back to your
kids classrooms
[Music]
let us
the father turns his face away
[Music]
below
is
[Music]
it was
until it was accomplished
his dying brethren
[Music]
but i will boast in jesus christ
his death and resurrection
[Music]
his wounds
i cannot give an answer
[Music]
his roads
would you guys join me in our prayer of
the people and if you're online join us
in the comments let's read this together
for this city of saxey texas and for
every city and community and all those
who live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us and the wisdom and the will to
conserve it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick for the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember
and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us and that
you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up
[Music]
from online a prayer of praise for james
townsend's parents gerald and nancy they
celebrated 62 years of marriage this
week
and continued prayers for
ukraine
health and teenagers
[Music]
for these names and moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
[Music]
i was created
to bury it alone
i hear your invitation
[Music]
so
my soul needs a friend so i run to the
father again and
again and again
[Music]
you saw my condition
you had a plan from the start
your son for redemption
the price for my heart
i don't have a contest
for that kind of love
i don't
understand i can't comprehend
all i know is
[Music]
oh
my heart has been in your
sight
long before my
first breath
running into
your
is
[Music]
so i
again
[Music]
scott thank you that we can go back
over and over
each day as we face new challenges
as new burdens come god that you are
always there ready for us to run back
and be renewed
be forgiven
be redeemed
you are always there
with compassion
with graciousness
with wisdom
with justice
god we look to you as our source
as our creator
as our sustainer
would you be ever present
would you be drawing us towards yourself
towards your heart
towards your ways
with the way that we live be
transformational in a broken world in in
the darkness would your light penetrate
would it find us
and would we share it god
would we spread your love
would we be your hands and feet
we don't want to just change for
ourselves
we want to change so that we can be good
in this world
so that we can be grace
so that we can be jesus to others
thank you for who you are thank you for
meeting us here
open our ears
share with us what you have on your
heart and it's in your name i pray
amen
well as you guys sit down you want to
turn to the people around you and
welcome them make them feel at home here
and brett will get us started on our
message
well good evening everyone
grace and peace
it is so good to be with you
and um i want to extend that welcome
also to those joining us online
i love you all lots and
especially to anyone here um or online
that's uh new and just kind of you know
finding finding their way um i know it
can take a lot of courage to come
through those doors
so
thank you um thank you for being here
with us so
um i also wanted to give some just a big
thank you to so many of you i won't name
names because i know i'll like forget
someone but just for easter and there
was a lot of time and energy that went
into that people there early saturday
people there early sunday morning and
then stay late and just the whole thing
so um you know who you are and uh thank
you so much for uh just that whole
experience it was really beautiful
service huh i really i i loved it i
loved it and praise the lord we met
inside oh my gosh that so worked out
beautifully
so um
so we are uh kind of returning uh to a
series it's titled first peter part
three um because we've kind of we we do
like a little part of first peter and we
leave it um because here at the table
we'll tend to kind of jump around some
um at times we'll join the church
calendar and do something like lent or
advent epiphany or something and then um
we'll jump off we'll do more topical
series on something that feels just i
don't know kind of
needed necessary timely for you know us
as a people um and then other times um
we'll just go through either a book of
the bible or a chapter or something so
that's kind of what we've been doing
with first peter
uh and i think that's it's it's helpful
um
i think it's you know in a day and age
when um we're not necessarily like the
bible just isn't culturally like what it
used to be in the sense of just oh it's
like the only book anyone owns you know
back like abe lincoln that was like
the book it's like that's the one book
you had in the house so everyone knew
the bible you know and it's just a
different day and age now and often we
um
you know aren't always as in the loop
one like what are these books um and we
get kind of pieces of them in sermons
you know or through liturgy a reading or
something so that's why one reason we
like to go through sections so um with
that in mind the uh the title of my
message tonight as we return to first
peter
is
in all caps internet yelling
evangelism
gulp
where i i want to actually start with a
question when i say evangelism
i'm really curious what words come to
mind
i know sometimes um
i ask very confusing rhetorical
questions in my sermons but this time i
actually mean it i really would like
feedback on uh
i say evangelism for those who are out
of the loop evangelism basically is the
the practice of sharing your faith in
christ with others
uh and uh often in hopes of like tied to
converting them you know basically
so uh so i'm curious event i say
evangelism
what words come to mind
failure okay
fun bible thumping fundamentalism
what was it
attract yeah like the little yeah what
was it
loud preaching
which i'm guilty of sometimes
anything else
judgment colonialism
door knocking yeah kind of the
door-to-door sales jesus sales kind of
yeah yeah
um
oh i got my work cut out for me tonight
no i know this is mostly what i expected
so i know y'all i know y'all many of you
know me so i think we're on the same
page here um
so let me i'm gonna return to that
feedback that'll come later in the
message um so let me start with a
reading this is uh first peter chapter 3
verses 15 and 16. he says but in your
hearts revere christ as lord
always be prepared to give an answer to
everyone who asks you to give the reason
for the hope that you have but do this
with gentleness and respect keeping a
clear conscience so that those who speak
maliciously against your good behavior
in christ may be ashamed of their
slander you can tell there that the
church he's speaking to they're facing
persecution um not necessarily like
martyrdom kind of persecution but um job
loss
um
social kind of just the stigma against
being a christian and you know kind of
social isolation things like that so
that's probably what he's referring to
there in uh in verse 16. um
so
i uh as i was reflecting on this this is
one good thing about preaching through a
book is you just preach on the next
thing right so here it is
and um
i was kind of reflecting on and i
thought you know there's probably kind
of two
two groups of people here tonight um i
probably one group uh someone yelled out
failure
maybe there's one group that feels like
when they hear that passage you know
hear the word evangelism then read a
passage about you know give a reason for
the hope that you have you know to
others people who don't need jesus share
your faith you know so one group
probably is like oh gosh like just
feeling a little like maybe guilty like
i know i should i should i should be
spreading the good news you know tell
another i just i just don't or i don't
feel prepared or i don't know enough and
i just i'm not doing that you know so
there's probably one group that feels a
little bit
um maybe guilty
um
now
then there's another another group um
based on the feedback i was the the key
words i think this is probably the the
larger group which works out well
because this is kind of who i'm mostly
gearing the message for um
and this the second group um
[Music]
you know well it's the words y'all
mentioned uh some of the language i
wrote down was evangelism it can it can
stop it can sound quite um pushy
um judgey
you know uh i have a quote this is from
richard beck um a christian psychologist
and and writer
and he says this he's writing about um
kind of progressive uh
christians
um who often you know kind of can
struggle with
the idea of evangelism and i think he
sums it up well he says this the
progressive impulse towards tolerance
and inclusion leaves progressive
christians in an awkward position in
regards to evangelism that is you know
sharing the gospel with non-believers
evangelism smacks of judgmentalism
i'm right
and you're wrong
worse evangelism contend
toward colonialism it's the history some
of you are familiar with this history
history of white missionaries being sent
to save the uh you know so-called kind
of dark um pagans the savages you know
that that language is is like replete in
christian history um and it's uh not not
good there's a whole shadow side you
know to this and um
so
i i think let me kind of just start by
by naming what i think is maybe a
good side to the hesitance
of um kind of what what richard beck is
naming um
and and that i from the feedback some of
where i think many of us are um the
hesitancy you know what how do i do this
in a way that's not like just weird and
you know have all sorts of feelings
about this so let me name the good the
good side of this i think is um
at its best it puts us in much more of a
posture where we are ready to dialogue
with people
rather than monologue
and i think that is like
two thumbs up if i could do with this
mic two thumbs up uh to that that's a
good i think that's a a wonderful thing
to to not be in that because at its
worst um let me finish that thought uh
at its
worst evangelism can kind of be this um
it's what beck named i'm right you're
wrong i'm the bible
or christian answer person
um and i sort of assume that you person
you know you my
evangelism victim here you know you know
nothing you know nothing and in fact um
in fact really god has never been
present to you or active in your life
and culture really in any way
until
ta-da
i showed up
can you see how that's like yikes and so
that's i think is the good part to this
um
kind of the hesitance and the being
aware of the history and and that kind
of thing in us it's like i don't know
about me just
getting out there with jesus sales and
it's just something in me is
feels weird you know i think that's the
good part is it pushes us towards a more
of a dialogue um
now the i think some of the the downside
or the the challenge to this more
progressive perspective um
is actually it's summed up well by a
theologian i really appreciate his work
his name is tripp fuller if you're into
podcasts he runs um home brewed
christianity
and a good uh it's a great theological
podcast but um
he uh he's he's kind of speaking
to
[Music]
what it's kind of known as theological
um well kind of uh
well let me use the term so he calls it
liberal laryngitis
now he doesn't mean liberal like
political liberalism for those who are
like liberal and we get all triggered
with certain words um he's talking about
theological um kind of liberal or
progressive perspective those are kind
of clunky terms with a whole history but
hopefully y'all generally know kind of
what i'm talking about you know and kind
of what he means by liberal laryngitis
is basically we can kind of um
enter into either a season of life or
maybe just kind of become a person who
you know we do all the deconstructing we
ask all the questions we um you know
question all the beliefs of our
childhood and kind of interrogate and um
and a lot of that's
helpful you know um but we kind of do
that to such a degree
that um
our kind of beliefs are left in a little
bit of shambles and we no longer can
really speak of god anymore
with like any confidence whatsoever
and that's what he's calling liberal
laryngitis you know the the of course
laryngitis the losing the voice you know
and um
and so i think the
the trick is some of what i want to do
in this message is kind of help us find
a little bit of a middle way you know
somewhere between
a posture a really problematic posture
of i know everything you know
or i know absolutely nothing honestly
i'm just as baffled and confused as you
are and uh
i've got nothing you know um i'll just
be clear i think there's it's okay to um
if you find yourself in that place i'm
not trying to like shame you know people
or something i'm just naming that um
it's
it's i think good to keep kind of if
you're on a journey like to keep on
moving you know and to keep on um
moving towards christ and and being able
to um still
speak of the god we've come to know in
jesus
that's like beautiful
and good and helpful so
what i want to do is kind of come back
to our passage because i think peter
actually names some things that are
quite helpful in this regard for kind of
charting a way forward
for us so you know for those who have
been here at the table a while you know
nearly all of my sermons are pointless
but tonight i have four points
in my sermon
so nay
four
steps oh my gosh i know i wrote it and i
was like of steps
but it just this is how it came out and
sometimes i don't really control what i
write it's a strange you know process
anyone who's written you know just kind
of it is what it is so
here you go four steps uh to kind of
helping us you know share faith so first
um
keep jesus lord
keep jesus lord the way um peter of
course puts it is but in your hearts use
the word revere you know honor christ as
lord
and um
i think what's kind of interesting about
this this idea you know it may sound
very christian-y or you know the lord
the good lord keep jesus lord revere
christ as lord um
but actually i think it's a i don't
think it's just about you know
christians do this weird thing of
believing you know having a lord um i
think actually
really to be human is is always already
to to have someone um kind of
functioning as
lord um maybe the way i could kind of
say that a little more succinct way
someone or something is always already
playing the role of lord in our life
you know
and the only question is how
how good
is
that person or thing
you know in other words we all have um
some sort of
vision
um
of what is good what is beautiful what
is true
like we can't i mean honestly we just
can't help in our lives but aim
towards something
right and in essence what happens is
that person or that thing
functions
like god in our life um
functions like our lord
and i think this can be maybe
helpful for us because um you know
living in kind of the the secular age
that we do it's easy to feel a little
bit weird about being a person you know
of um
of faith you know of someone who has
faith in god and follows christ and
makes him lord you know like oh is that
weird am i strange for you know
declaring jesus lord and it's like well
you know honestly as human beings we
don't totally like get the choice i mean
we choose kind of who or what but
whether or not to have someone or
something function in that way well
that's like happening
that's that thing that's already
happening so in essence as christians we
just sort of um well and if there's any
i think maybe like you might say an
upside to following christ it's that um
it's everything we talked about last
week if you're here for easter like
jesus is just so good and so beautiful
and so compassionate
and and what's amazing is that when our
image of god is shaped by him
then what happens to us like he's a
really good lord and suddenly we find
our own hearts and minds and lives like
being transformed into his image
and that's
that's amazing that's why we might say
you know choose your lord wisely
choose your lord wisely
this uh
it reminds me of if any of you can go
online and listen to david foster
wallace's uh little speech this is water
this is water i didn't i've quoted it
before in sermon so i didn't want to do
it again but wonderful talk it's
basically him as really not he's not
like a bible-believing person he's not
really i don't even know if he's really
a christian by the end of his life but
he was someone who
um kind of realized oh my gosh i'm
always already worshipping
something or someone i'm giving my life
for something or someone so oh he says
he's speaking to uh undergraduates he's
like choose wisely friends
choose wisely because if
he
he basically names like if um because if
it's money
if it's um beauty
if it's career
like these things ultimately he's
basically name it they're bad lords and
they'll eat you up
they'll eat you alive like they promise
everything and then deliver just
dust
um
so to be christian is to we start there
step one we revere christ as lord um
step number two is we allow people um
allow people to move toward you
toward you i loved this did you catch it
in there he says always be prepared to
give an answer to everyone who does what
key word huh
keyword to everyone who asks
you
um
i think it's it's interesting where so
much evangelism has gone
is like not that
you know it's
and we might assume that i don't know
somewhere in the bible talks about
getting on the corners with a bullhorn
and
just yelling at people to convert them
you know or something like but that's
just not there
like instead what you what you have is
him encouraging like basically his
assumption is hey you'll be in
relationship like in friendship
connection with people
and at some point
they might be curious
and there's a conversation happening in
that moment
and so
respond
respond like to everyone who
asks you um for taking notes you can
write this down don't try to convince
people who aren't moving toward you
this by the way applies to a lot of
things
i mean our country right now like our
think of our politics
you know
we're like so
upset at each other
everyone's just was basically our social
media streams you know just people
yelling out
i believe this i believe you know i mean
and um
and
there's something quite futile about
trying to
change someone
who isn't saying
hey i would i'm interested
i'm curious i might like some
transformation i'm not like that's
can you see how that's like a very
different posture
that's a i just think this is um
so so key i had actually um a little
moment this was last uh
june
i took some time off from the table and
so i was taken um dax and uh my son dax
and my niece harper to a soccer camp
each morning at celebration park in
allen
and uh
i just it was really cool was there
there like three hours and i just had
time and space you know i was on
vacation so i was taking some books and
y'all know me so i was just sitting
there in the silence and all the books
and just oh i was so good it was amazing
um but the one day i'm sitting there i
think i was actually um doing some i
practiced something called sin room
prayer kind of a christian form of like
meditation and so i'm just sitting there
celebration park i mean there's like no
one around for i mean it's huge park
have you been there just massive and no
one's around i'm just sitting there
doing my center in prayer and all of a
sudden i can you know it's weird how you
can like sense someone is like upon me
you know
and i just kind of opened my and there's
these like teenagers and they're like hi
i was like oh my gosh hello
uh
and
they basically start asking me all these
questions and within like a few seconds
cause you know i used to be them i knew
like oh
you looked out here doing some
evangelism you know and um
started asking me you know all these
questions and of course i mean they
don't i don't know they don't know i was
a pastor obviously you know um and i
didn't tell him i wasn't i don't know i
was gonna be that guy and uh but i was
curious about their whole tone and like
where is this go how are they gonna
handle this you know and um
honestly it was um
well it was really awkward
the whole it was interesting to be kind
of on the other side you know here i am
they're trying to convert me being
converted you know and it was like a
moment to see through another's eyes and
i'm like oh
oh gosh oh no no no no this is this
feels really
this is kind of icky you know it was
just it was just weird probably because
i just had no relationship with them i
didn't ask them to come up to me
you know i mean like i don't know
how is
of course god can use anything so you
know i'm not saying it's never been used
effectively but something about the
whole encounter it was just so weird and
i was reflecting on it this week and i
was thinking a huge piece of it is that
i didn't ask you know i didn't ask i
wasn't in that posture of like inviting
them into my world and like come on in
and let's have a jesus convo right here
right now you know what i mean
and uh lord bless him i didn't i didn't
ever tell him who i was but i you know
that was a pastor anything i was just
like yeah i actually i do i attend a
church
and uh
you know god's good i just was trying to
say any kind of words that would maybe
convince them and then they could you
know scurry on off and uh it was it was
cute but um the point is we need like i
think this even applies you know um for
like parents
you know there's a fine line between um
inviting our kids into the faith
modeling the faith well
loving them well inviting them even in
the rhythms and you know um
we had our kids up here tonight you know
like inviting them into the rhythms of
the faith and yet at the same time not
crossing a line where we're forcing
you know manipulating
guilt-tripping when they're not going
the path we want
you know and if that's true from parents
to children like how much more true is
that with co-workers
extended family friends
like let's let's
let's wait till people ask
and as we relate i think god opens up
those doors all right so that's second
third
third is let your hope speak he says
always be prepared to give an answer to
everyone who asks you to give the reason
for the hope that you have
i think it's interesting here the words
he doesn't use
doesn't say
uh give an answer everyone asks to give
reason for the theology
that you have the beliefs that you have
the clever arguments the proofs the
certainty that you have
instead it's interesting isn't it that
he says the word hope
i think it's such um
it's such a personal word
you know i mean like that's different
than
lead them through a bible study of the
book of romans
you know or give them a short homily on
the meaning of the word gospel
you know like it's not that it's just
give a reason for the hope that you have
in other words it seems like his
assumption is there's something
beautiful happening inside you
like where there was despair
where there was a sense of loss
there like a new hope is starting to
happen inside you which by the way
doesn't mean like my life's perfect now
you know it's not that
but it's
um
this faith is doing something beautiful
in me
and people see it
and they're curious
that i i think that's i love that
because it's so personal and it invites
you just to share a story
basically why where where were you and
why do you have such hope now
and that's like
that's i think a beautiful invitation a
beautiful opportunity just to to share
and and often we i think feel
intimidating because like i don't know
all the theology or all the i don't know
what to say you know
and yet it's just like we'll just share
about the hope
just share the hope and honestly like i
have um
you know interact with quite a few
people in my in my role and not just
church folks all sorts of folks
and um people are looking for hope
there's a lot of despair
a lot of a lot of despair out there a
lot of a sense of kind of
meaninglessness we got all the things
all the toys
um careers and money and
i mean like more than previous
generations for sure and yet we're just
like what is what is the point
you know what's it all it sort of comes
back to the lord thing our lords are
proving somewhat futile
so all you have to do is just share
the hope
let your hopes speak um and then fourth
and finally
he says let your emotional tone
uh be gentleness and respect the way
peter puts it is but do this with
gentleness and respect so we started um
this message with that poll
uh
and it was it's interesting you know the
words that weren't said
uh and by the way i'm not in any way
blaming you for that like i think no
that's fair i think a lot of the words
you're sharing is quite accurate
you know um but it's kind of names what
a sad state our christian communities
are in you know that when we hear the
word sharing the faith of jesus christ
with others the words that don't come to
mind like no one yelled out gentleness
you know and i say evangelism what do
you think gentleness the gentle spirit
of the loving christ you know said no
one ever like
it just
or what's this other word respect you
know when i say evangelism what do you
think respect respect for my own story
and other stories and we dialogue and
god meets us in beautiful ways in the
midst like nope that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about jesus
sales you know like get those people out
of hell you know it's like oh man we've
a lot we've lost our way haven't we
we just we've kind of lost we've lost
our way
and um
this is what really we're just what he's
describing here is just about character
it's about there's some beautiful
process that happens where the character
of christ oh slowly over time becomes
our character
such that the gentleness of christ
becomes our gentleness and that becomes
beautiful
just beautiful to people
so um
as we come to the table tonight i want
us
to come in the posture of
what peter named of revering christ as
lord
as re-centering
on his broken body symbolized in the
bread
the blood shed for us
symbolized in the wine
and it may it be just a moment of saying
jesus i'm re-centering on you
um fill me with your life fill me with
your hope and may your gentleness and
kindness and compassion
become mine
and may that be beautiful and compelling
to people in the world
so let me uh
invite you to the table
with these words
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more
so come
you who have much faith
and you
who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you who have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the lord himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him
should meet him here
come to the table
so
foreign
um
so
[Music]
we're gonna sing a new song as we close
out tonight it's called brighter days
and what i loved about it um brett
introduced me to this song and
um i just felt like
what he's talking about tonight us
offering hope to others
this is the message this is the message
of hope of someone sometimes stepping in
and believing for us when we can't
believe for ourselves
of sometimes someone holding
the candle
when we can't hold it anymore you know
keeping the faith for us
even when we're falling behind or
falling short
that's the beauty of the gospel is that
it's not only about me it's about all of
us and about offering the hope of jesus
to each other to one another
so um if you guys want we stand with us
i know it's gonna be probably a newer
song to most of us but i just encourage
you to try to sing along as you catch on
to it and uh let's sing this for
ourselves but also for the other people
in this room with us and for those in
our life that you might have shared
their name during the prayer of the
people someone who is struggling someone
who feels far from god even
and let's hold hope in our hearts for
them let's offer that to one another all
right
[Music]
veins i know there's gonna be some
brighter days
i know there's gonna be some better days
[Music]
if to breathe
there's gonna be some brighter days
i know there's gonna be some brighter
days
oh
if your screams don't
[Music]
oh
i swear
[Music]
i know there's gonna be somebody
brighter days
[Music]
days
i know there's gonna be some brighter
[Music]
days
i know there's gonna be some better days
i know there's gonna be some
[Music]
okay i know what's going on my spotify
playlist
as soon as i leave here that was i love
that it's like our anthem our new anthem
blessing of four that's the guy who does
it blessing a blessing o4 all right
there you go
i'm so glad that you all were here here
and online thank you for joining us
tonight don't forget about our online
book club that starts up tomorrow if
you're interested in that you can
message the table you can ask me about
it you can fill out the communication
card put it in the box back there
also don't forget next sunday first
sundays
uh hat creek burger company after
service next week
also if you're in need of prayer or just
would like somebody to talk to me brett
and mindy will be in the back
immediately after the service so feel
free to stop by and and we'll pray for
you talk to you whatever you need we'd
be happy to do that
um
so as you go into your week
how about a benediction
yeah all right all right if you're
comfortable doing so you can hold out
your hands
to receive these words
that are true for every single one of
you
every single one of you
you are a child of god
you
are a child of god
this is true on your best day
and it's especially true on your worst
day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between
go with the assurance that you are loved
you are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit
and the desire to extend these gifts
of love
grace
hope and compassion to everyone you come
in contact with
be blessed
have a great week and we hope to see you
back here next sunday good
[Music]
there's night be some brighter days
i know there's gonna be some
brighter days
[Music]
you